die wunderschönen abend die haben wieder
das großes vor ich treffe mich nämlich
als country im ufo weiblicher
interessiert wie sieht es mittlerweile
aus dem ganzen mehr als übel vergammeln
oder sind ja immer komplett leer wie
selbst bei wie den up alle rallye und
wie sie aussieht kann bis zur wirklichen
konnte war das für dich an gestartet wir
finden uns jetzt mittlerweile ist der
einst liebevoll das 500 spaß macht weiß
gar nicht wann ich das letzte mal hier
war es schon ewig gar nichts zu tun
gehabt dass ich schon da bin ich mal
gespannt wie ist da oben es ausgibt was
aus den einfachen zimmer geworden ist so
wie sie träume mittlerweile aber sind
eigentlich immer noch so vielfachen im
jahr alle freunde mein gott es ist echt
regiert hier eine befriedigung einfach
komplett leer ist so fallen hieß es
später keine freunde
es geht raus das passte kamera dabei ich
habe da einen einband award dabei aber
dann einwohner ort kriegst du kannst
oder millionen karten aller kratzt du
kriegst einmal der ort erst wenn ich das
mit orangen träge fließt
okay ich bin sicher dass gutes teamwork
dabei ist heute aber auch der mich ja
hallo mich anrief war zusammen mit
michaels vater den schreibtisch marie
april nimmt jetzt nämlich mich aktionen
kulissen oder ja stark ab man das muss
ich auch einfach noch putzen jetzt
gleich da geht man hier kurz zu felix
überzeugen schon mal anfällig sind jetzt
immer gefragt ist alles komplett leer
ist hier ein durchgang geht die dieses
gemeinschaften wirkt es ist echt total
komisch das ist hier so viel übrig haben
wir auch ja was denn er ist was ist also
im klaren so weit hinten auf jeden fall
war das eine zweite schon recht ein
komisches gefühl wenn man mal bedenkt
dass hier alles passiert es wie hier
hastig wie hier in diesem jahr einfach
die legendäre wasserschlacht war die
wasserrutsche kommen wir da nicht auch
die gefühle hoch
wir kommen so bald wie sieht es da aus
auch palestrinas hamas und ein zimmer
betreten hier ist echt freuen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen hier sind
echt voller geworden ehrlich gesagt habe
ich dieses zimmer noch nie so voll
gewesen was ich für meinen teil
eingestellt
dieses regal das apropos küche wo mein
gott ohne kühlschrank beenden ohne den
tisch und auch sogar der wurde aus dem
motto das ist hier so ok hat sich noch
nichts verändert kindern ein bisschen
ungewaschen das geschirr ja das also bei
den linken geschehen da kommen recht
gefühl weil ich immer grund dass wir sie
auch die sie tut mir leid dass ich jetzt
auch hier mal
sie werden jetzt gar nicht so weit weg
nicht einmal einstellen dass ich noch
ziemlich gut aus tatsächlich ich hatte
immer die kamera ein und sehen wir das
weil es regal hier auf der linken seite
fehlt aber seine pcs und hier verfahren
ist auch neugier bei easy hat sich am
wenigsten tatsächlich verändert aber
klar so bundesliga ist natürlich
komplett weg an der stelle
ja aber das regal ist auf jeden fall
schon mal leer das ist geil hier ist
auch lehrer hat wenn ihr mal sind die
ganzen erwerb des ganzen trubels ja wie
ist es mal hart zu arbeiten
[Musik]
hallo nicht erkannt werden ja dass ich
guck mal reden so nochmal um alter da
ist wo auch das wert war
jetzt kommt ein lehrer auch hier war mal
sein schreibtisch gut der strategie hin
dass das ist dass man auch hier die
pflanze die stand vor ein paar wochen
nämlich auch noch gut also ja auch nicht
stehen was hier soll es vom liegt hier
in sechs ein wichtiges wort an der
stelle zieht man die produktiv regen
würde ich unseren tagen geplanten
wichtige notizen hier vor allem die hier
die beim extrem wurde auch für ganz oben
von der motivation bild richtig stark
hier war immer mein schreibtisch hier
habe ich immer noch und für die ganzen
police der jungs ja recht national und
auch da ist eine hinterlassenschaft von
einem trank was tatsächlich philippinen
gemacht hat das war der verein den
freddy wie auch ein revier ist eine
interessante erfahrung wie gesagt weil
man mal bedenkt wie viel leben hier drin
war und ich sag jetzt aussieht weiß ich
genau das gegenteil ist ich bin jetzt ja
gar nicht irgendwie melancholisch oder
so es kann ja alle irgendwie
kohleprojekte nach dem start und hat
sich alles weiterentwickelt wir gehen
jetzt auch ins neue büro von redit einer
sache recht wohl tragen muss man sagen
aber nichts desto trotz war echt ne
geile zeit hier vor allem leben gekommen
war dieses youtube noch heute neu für
mich und da habe ich ja gerade erst
angefangen videos zu machen was ihnen
auch ein paar guidetti und es entstanden
guten morgen so ich bin jetzt beim ufer
angekommen habe gerade schon
gefrühstückt und jetzt ist es 9 uhr 30
das heißt jetzt will dass mein video
geschnitten was nicht ja das war also
ganz neu so da hab ich halt kommt
angefangen erstmal mit der kamera zu
reden
ich weiß nicht hier treten erste video
ist nämlich bei regen zu sehen war war
hier auf dieser couch die hat jetzt
nicht mehr da stehe ich weiß gar nicht
was ich sagen soll das war dieses video
die quasi für sich entdeckt haben was
ich extrem geil fand aber da habe ich so
viel arbeit reingesteckt
[Musik]
hat sich aber echt gelohnt alter werden
von denen die mich da schon vorzustellen
und generell nicht überhaupt soja ist
trans ocean ich hatte also das
vielleicht heftig zu der zeit weisen
nämlich noch immer mehr werden wie hier
in köln hat sich noch keine eigene
wohnung und dafür glaubt auch meine
schwester und ihre freundin zu besuch
bei mir in kairo und kann ich mich noch
genau erinnern
da bin ich halt ein quasi der nach hause
gegangen zur wm und habe danach diesem
video über nacht wie von 800 auf über
10.000 abonnenten politik gekriegt das
war echt zugelegt hat was also wenn ich
könig rechts unterlag war das machen die
wenigsten ist ja die meisten youtube
mittlerweile katze aber die wenigsten
geben das auch so offen zu bz viele
games zu aber die wenigsten hängen das
so an die große glocke wir deswegen
riesen herrenknecht der isi ist gerade
auch noch aufgetaucht
wie es der zufall denn will das war's
dann allein zu hause mal ich wurde ja es
hat ja doch nicht mitbekommen dass das
jetzt jetzt meine das heißt alle mein
leben gemacht habe bei partys aus dem
ganzen würde und so richtig also
eigentlich könnte hier einziehen können
ja auf jeden fall und letzte vertrauen
hat jetzt kann er gestand ich sag mal so
paul überhaupt das eine oder andere mag
ich habe schon stories gehört von paul
klee und jetzt sagt er war auch hier ein
bisschen weh lang gestört und lag dann
als die couch noch immer wieder oder
soja auch ein haus und der war beim
rennen und man kann nicht besichtigt
haben die anderen machen und holte am
fenster wo ich bin jetzt denke zum
verwalter paul dann zu beginn ja klar
stock ist in frage da ich dachte
eigentlich jetzt schon alles über
transportiert aber krass ja ich benutze
es nur noch zum livestream oder jetzt ab
morgen wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
lösen hat hier einfach spannend mit müll
angesammelt und essen bestellt würde
sagte servern und ansonsten ist ja
eigentlich klar will man doch gerade das
macht für sie hätte ich nicht gedacht
ich komm mir so rein und das ist der
letzte flexibel in riesa kam da hatte
ich nie aufgeben weil das vielleicht
einfach von der leyen
ich mache das auch richtig weg es ist
keine halte ich meine pflanze ist nicht
schön hast du dich gar nicht mehr
pflegen
siehst du das und ich weiß gar nicht wie
jetzt wo es so gut läuft schon gehört
aber ich hab' ich habe vorgestern
gestern geschnittene hecken ja ich glaub
ich hab hecke geschnitten so saß
vorgestern aus wie kann es sinnvoll sein
die die klasse halten wird ausgelassen
zu feiern gilt
ich habe mich als profi hunter das ist
auch sehr spannend im wasser ich hab
dich hält der muss erst mal ganz stark
ich bin schon bei der bewerbung
ausgemacht
rausgeworfen weil die felder sehe ich ja
auch egal ja endet und mit welcher wir
haben diesen aufgaben biologistischen
mitnehmen für uns geht es dann auch
gleich ins neue büro und ein verstehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
extrem wichtige starthilfe rings gehen
wir das letzte mal im beruf sowieso
nicht haben ein video heißt so mann
[Musik]